good news everybody Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi solved racism it took a
long time but they managed to do it they
did it specifically by ridiculously
wearing Kente African scarves and then
making really really serious faces and
then kneeling down here is Nancy Pelosi
announcing the brilliant plan for those
who wish to we will now kneel for our
moment of silence
now in fairness in Nancy Pelosi's
defense Nancy Pelosi being quiet for
several consecutive minutes is the most
effective thing she's ever done to
improve race relations in America so
that is some good news
same goes for Chuck Schumer everybody is
kneeling these days everybody even the
people who didn't use to kneel
everybody is kneeling against America
against the nation that's a big change
and if we want to conserve our country
we've got to quit talking and we've got
to be just like Nancy Pelosi and we've
got to take some bold action ourselves
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
lots of kneeling and the kneeling is
very very bad
I got to ask you right off the top in
the comments section please let me know
which your favorite fictional character
is is your favorite fictional character
of the past few weeks Batman or is it
the Tooth Fairy or is it Bigfoot or is
it the peaceful protestors I really want
to know please please put your answer
down in the comments section we've got a
lot to get to right off the top at first
I've got to thank our friends over at
arrow era is Wi-Fi that your home
deserves at blankets your whole home
with fast reliable Wi-Fi not just inside
but outside too euro extends your
coverage so that you can enjoy the nicer
weather and get work done from your deck
which these days could be very very
helpful
I love euro my favorite thing about euro
is that it is incredibly easy to install
I am a Luddite okay I don't understand
technology at all euro makes it so
simple to set up and it fixes those
problems of spotty Wi-Fi or your Wi-Fi
doesn't work over here it's really
really tremendous stuff apple homekit
users euros got you covered with
enhanced privacy and safety controls
that give connected devices only the
permissions they need to do what you
want in your home and on the internet
you can get yours fixed as soon as
tomorrow tomorrow go to ero comm slash
nulls then enter code NOLs and check out
to get free next day shipping with your
order that's eer Oh Dom slash Noel's
code Noel's at checkout to get your
arrow delivered with free next day
shipping but you must use this URL to
receive this offer erode comm slash
Noel's code Noel's can't get enough
Noel's you know I think of all the the
fictional characters of the last few
weeks I think my favorite or the
peaceful protesters because while Batman
might be a cooler figure the peaceful
protesters are just so much more
fantastical they've made a new
appearance this this in the BBC an
actual BBC headline George Floyd London
anti racism protests leave 27 officers
hurt okay that's sort of a more
believable title here's how the
tweeted out the headline 27 police
officers injured during largely peaceful
anti-racism protests in London that is
not possible that is that tweet is a
nonsense because 27 cops can't be
injured in largely peaceful protests you
can't have those things at the same time
from the article protests unsaid they
sparked by the death of George Floyd is
that true we'll get to that in a second
we're largely peaceful but were marred
later by disturbances outside of Downing
Street you know they were largely
peaceful to protest themselves but they
were marred that's unfortunate because
they were so peaceful but they were
marred later by disturbances not
violence not the people committing the
violence one demonstrator who is not a
Downing Street saw officers acting very
aggressively elsewhere it was the
officers acting aggressively you see and
they shouldn't do that that's what not
not what officers are for they're not
there to use force they're there to
enforce the law wait a second force and
force let's not let's ignore it let's
ignore that the entire purpose of the
police is to use force for just one
second the majority of Saturday's
protests were peaceful but in the
evening there were disturbances outside
Downing Street BBC home affairs
correspondent Tom Simmons said the
protests were largely over when missiles
and fireworks were thrown at a police
line they were thrown and not by the
protesters just these were thrown two
officers were seriously injured
including a mounted branch officer who
was knocked from her horse when it hit a
set of traffic lights while appearing to
bolt
she suffered a broken collarbone a
broken rib a punctured lung according to
the Metropolitan Police Federation
that's not nothing ok those are real
injuries those are serious injuries
those were caused by the allegedly
nonviolent protests now you can actually
see their number of videos that came out
the protests got so violent that the
police eventually ran away from the
so-called peaceful protesters you can
see there's some sort of chaos there
they're what people are throwing things
at the cops that's in America not quite
as well armed as their cops in Britain
rather not quite as well armed as those
in America eventually the police are
running away as these goons these thugs
these criminals are throwing objects at
them a lot of problems with policing in
the UK obviously they are not armed
to do the job that they're supposed to
do but the question here is why are
there protests going on in the United
Kingdom over the death of George Floyd
is it because people in the UK Brits
just really have a connection to this
man in Minneapolis and half the half a
world away
in the United States I don't think so I
think there's a deeper ideological
political rebellion going on here which
we will get to in a moment the symbol of
this protest all around the world but
especially in America is kneeling down
it's the symbol that Colin Kaepernick
has been using for years at this point
kneeling down specifically against the
flag and you remember when Colin
Kaepernick did it people didn't like it
very much
the NFL didn't support it there were
certain players in the NFL we're doing
it but it had a really negative reaction
now that's all over now even the NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell is saying
goodness gracious I wish that we had
endorsed the kneeling protest it was a
wonderful protest I support it now I
kneel with you
we the National Football League condemn
racism and the systematic oppression of
black people hold on stop right there
that is so brave Wow Roger Goodell
condemns racism and the systematic
oppression of black people Wow
God you know because they're all these
people out there who support racism
they're totally Pro racism they're Pro
oppression but not Roger Goodell
standing up such bravery such political
vision of course nobody supports those
things no but not one person now one
person will you see get on camera with
any influence whatsoever and say yes I'm
Pro racism Goodell is standing up
against a boogeyman he's standing up
against
an imaginary adversary because nobody is
for racism
actually the racism that exists the only
racism that exists in this country is a
little bit of sin lurking in everybody's
heart right but no one looks inside it
themselves at their own problems they
always look out at the imaginary
boogeyman evil monster so then Goodell
moves on gets to his point to support
the protests we the National Football
League admit we were wrong for not
listening to NFL players earlier and
encourage all to speak out and
peacefully protest read the National
Football League believe black lives
matter
I personally protest with you and want
to be part of the much-needed change in
this country so pathetic so totally
pathetic he is completely wrong he look
he's right in the in some of the words
he's saying right nobody believes black
lives don't matter nobody believes that
everybody thinks black lives matter and
everyone is pretending that there are a
lot of people out there who think that
black lives don't matter but those
people don't exist the black lives
matter movement is not based on black
lives mattering there is no systemic
slaughter of racist cops killing unarmed
black men in America it simply does not
exist
we went through the statistics on this
show yesterday we went through them last
week as well black lives matter does a
great job at pretending that it's a very
moderate simple group that just thinks
black lives matter that's not yet it is
a radical group advocating total
revolution in society including the
destruction of quote the Western
proscribed nuclear family that's how
radical it is it follows a long line of
radical movements that go back all the
way to Karl Marx this kind of argument
that Goodell is making is actually an
argument that conservatives need to
consider because it is an argument
against the kind of extreme libertarian
conservative who takes our respect for
free markets to an idolatress level okay
because the market is in many ways
dictating goodell x' decision here right
he thinks that the culture is shifted in
such a way there's an appetite among
consumers in such a way that he's got a
completely reverse course and now
protest the very flag of his own country
a symbol of the country itself that's
the market deciding that but the market
here is wrong it is wrong to do that
it's disrespectful it's wrong to lie
it's long drugs to accept premises that
are dishonest it's wrong simply to
disrespect ones flag especially when
that flag represents the most just free
prosperous equitable country in the
history of the world until just a few
moments ago even the most radically left
people in this country with any
influence we're anti-flag protests
including the great heralded Ruth Bader
Ginsburg we'll get to that in one second
and we'll get to a proper response to
all this first though I have got to
thank our friends over at We the People
holster you know I love we the people
holster it's very important to exercise
your Second Amendment rights and when
you do that you want to be safe you want
to make sure that your firearm is
protected you want to make sure that
you're protected starting in just $39 we
the people holsters are custom designed
to fit your firearm perfectly and they
are made right here in the US of A which
these days with some supply chain
questions that's a wonderful thing to
know they have thousands of options to
choose from plus an amazing selection of
printed holsters their proprietary clip
design allows for you to easily adjust
both the cam and ride of your holster so
that it will fit comfortably and
securely at all times now is the time to
support American companies I really love
these guys the designs are great and
they are just perfectly designed to fit
your firearm go to We the People
holsters comm slash Knowles KO wles
to get yours every holster ships free it
comes with a lifetime guarantee Plus now
as if that weren't good enough $39 for
an excellent holster you can get $10 off
when you use the offer code Knowles
now we're down to $29 for an excellent
high-quality really good-looking made in
America holster it's not going to beat
that anywhere satisfaction guaranteed if
it's not a perfect fit send it back for
a total refund we the people holsters
dot-com / Knowles ko wles so now
everybody's supporting these anti flag
protests until just a few moments ago
even
left in this country even the most
famous left-wing jurist in this country
was against it here's a clip from gee I
think it's just three or four years ago
now Katie Couric was interviewing a Ruth
Bader Ginsburg on this topic and said
what do you think of the Colin
Kaepernick protests RBG was unequivocal
she said they're stupid they're
disrespectful I don't like them Justice
Ginsburg how do you feel about San
Francisco 49ers player Colin Kaepernick
and other NFL players who have basically
refused to stand for the national anthem
and what do I think I think it's really
dumb of them what I arrest them for
doing it no I think he's dumb and
disrespectful the same I would have the
same answer if you asked me about flag
burning I said I think it's a terrible
thing to do but I wouldn't lock a person
up so that for doing it I would point
out how ridiculous it seems to me to do
such as such an a dumb and disrespectful
that's where his Bader Ginsburg you know
she sounds like Antonin Scalia on this
issue Antonin Scalia used to say the
same thing I think his line on it was if
I could throw in jail every scruffy
bearded weirdo who burns the American
flag I would if I were king but I am NOT
King and that that's basically RBG's
answer because no matter how far left
leftists used to be an American it was
very rare very uncommon for them to
attack the country itself and that's
what the flag protest is that's what the
kneeling protest is it's not kneeling
about police brutality its kneeling
about in protesting the star-spangled
banner which is the flag which is the
symbol of the country okay but the left
has moved radically left and these
latest movements of the last few weeks
have accelerated that process there was
a state trooper out there I actually I
wasn't able to get his name but there's
a state trooper out there who was filmed
on video talking to some of these
protesters hopefully the peaceful
protesters and he was asked about
kneeling this is a black trooper and he
said look I'm here
to protect your right to do all this but
I don't kneel for these kind of
political protests I only kneel to God
for one person and that's God I like it
i like this guy's attitude I like how he
talks I like what he's saying you might
go a little bit broader than that okay
because some you know I think people
kneel for other reasons than God at
least sometimes like for instance if I
were in the United Kingdom and I were
about to be made a knight you know I was
gonna be Sir Michael someday a boy can
dream I would kneel down and you know I
get the sword on me you get kneel for
that you can kneel if you're Catholic or
Eastern Orthodox or Anglican you can
kneel and other sorts of Prayer you know
in contemplative prayer or people kneel
when they're meditating for instance
okay fine you could say more broadly
kneeling is a sign of respect right and
this is what's so weird about the
kneeling protests other than people
protesting their own country is that
kneeling has become a sign of disrespect
the left does this to everything they
invert everything and they've done it
even with the kneeling so now the
kneeling is a sign of disrespect where
does this come from I mean where do you
get this kind of situation where people
are actively protesting their own
country it has been building up on the
left for a long time and our most recent
actual left-wing president brought this
out in people his wife Michelle Obama
was just giving a graduation speech
unzoom for all of America and she she
explained this kind of left-wing
activism this kind of left wing
character which is to stay angry she did
she said be angry don't let anyone ever
tell you not to be angry she begins by
more or less disrespecting and denying
the reality of the American Dream but
here's the thing
while this period is certainly
unprecedented it is not a complete
anomaly simply some random coincidence
to be dismissed
now what's happening right now is the
direct result of decades of unaddressed
prejudice and inequality the truth is
when it comes to all those tiny stories
of hard work and self-determination that
we'd like to tell ourselves about
America well the reality is a lot more
complicated than that because for too
many people in this country no matter
how hard they work there are structural
barriers working against them that just
make the road longer and rockier and
sometimes it's almost impossible to move
upward at all because if you're required
to work during a pandemic but don't have
enough protective equipment or health
insurance from your employer or paid
sick leave well what is more essential
your work or your life there it is
there's the classic it's impossible you
can't succeed America's never gonna work
for some people it's interesting that in
this clip she went back to the pandemic
because it seems to me that so many
left-wing rioters peaceful rioters have
been ignoring the allegedly
extraordinarily deadly pandemic for the
past two three weeks as they've poured
out by the hundred thousand to protest
right but that then at that point they
ignored the pandemic the public health
officials said it's actually good to go
protest don't worry about the pandemic
we'll worry about the pandemic later so
it's interesting that she focused on
that because it seems so odd but it's
also interesting that she the wife of
the first black president who was
elected twice talks about how America's
hopelessly racist hopelessly unjust
there's no way to succeed I mean this is
boilerplate left-wing stuff and what
they have to do is tell you as Americans
that you can't succeed this place is
hopelessly unjust you are simply useless
you can't you can't do anything on your
own because it justifies more and more
policies that give them greater control
over the country that undermine our
country's political traditions and
undermine your very ability to pull
yourself up that's where she begins how
does she foment the kind of political
action that she's calling for she tells
people to be angry
you who feel invisible please know that
your story matters your ideas matter
your experiences matter your vision for
what our world can and should be matters
so don't ever ever let anyone tell you
that you're too angry or that you should
keep your mouth shut
uh here's my message to the left in
America you're too angry and you should
keep your mouth shut
that's my I know it's a different
message that Michelle Obama is giving
you but that is my message the left
pushes anger because when people get
really angry they don't think straight
because anger is an easy emotion it's
the eat it's the easiest emotion to play
it's the easiest emotion to live drew
Clavin says that anger is the devil's
cocaine anger is the devil's cocaine it
unleashes bad things in Italian culture
we have a suspicious iliyan culture here
in America we have an expression which
is don't get mad get even right the idea
being when you're angry you're not
you're not going to be able to control
yourself as well you're not able to
think as well so get even calm down that
anger but the left encourages that anger
because that anger makes you more easy
to manipulate you can see people running
on the absurdity of this anger all the
way at some of the highest levels in
government AOC recently used it to
humiliate herself we'll get to that in
one second first though I have got to
thank our friends over at LifeLock you
know the April 15th tax filing deadline
was pushed off until July 15th you're
probably relieved by this right trouble
is there's a downside the extension also
gives additional time to fraudsters to
mine for data that they can sell so
proactive approaches to protection are
more important than ever after all the
Government Accountability Office found
that fraudsters used false identities to
steal at least one point six eight
billion dollars billion with a B in tax
refunds in 2016 everyone every single
day is at risk for these sorts of things
every day we put our information at risk
on the Internet cyber criminals around
the world keep finding new ways to steal
identities you could miss certain
identity threats by just monitoring your
credit good thing there's life lock now
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions in all
businesses but with life lock you can
see threats that you might miss on your
own
I just these guys these are the guys
that I trust to protect my identity
right now you can join and save up to
25% off your first year the way to do
that it's going to LifeLock comm /
Knowles canna wles that's a Lifeloc
dot-com / Knowles
canna wles for 25% off get it now
because this tax filing deadline is
going to keep you vote herbal even
longer than you usually would be
Michelle Obama says be angry be angry be
angry okay
and this clouds people's thinking the
best example of this I saw was a OC
yesterday a OC complaining about how
people weren't giving her enough
adulation a SC tweets a quote the press
secretary Kaley mcenany wouldn't be the
first person to mistake a woman of color
for having a lower position or title
than she does
but Kaley in case you haven't picked up
a newspaper in two years I'm a
congresswoman so now I saw this tweet I
thought wait did Caitlin mcenany not
refer to a OC by her title I mean you
know come on insisting on someone using
their your own title is a silly thing
and it's a prideful thing to do anyway
especially if your congresswoman but
maybe she didn't do it
because a OC went on she goes the press
secretary cumin is steeped in a long
hurtful and horrendous history of
stripping women of color of titles and
diminishing them to the help perhaps she
isn't aware that what she did is mired
in racist history if that is the case I
look forward to her apology tomorrow I
said gosh this press secretary Kaley
mcenany she is a disrespectful and a
racist and all my and what did she do
the allegation is that that the press
secretary did not refer to AOC as a
congresswoman so is that what really
happened here's Kaley mackaninee the
president is appalled by the defund the
police movement the fact that you have
sitting Congress women wanting to defund
the police notably Rasheeda to leave
notably Biden advisor AOC
Andrea Ocasio Cortez a former Clinton
and Eric Holder spokesperson Brian
Fallon wanting to defund our police
across this country it is extraordinary
hold on pause there she referred to AOC
as a congresswoman she said you've got
prominent congresswoman notably she
names some of the squad notably AOC she
notes that in addition to being a
congresswoman AOC is a Biden adviser
because frankly it's more impressive to
be a Biden adviser than it is to be a
member of Congress right there are fewer
Biden advisers than there are members of
Congress but she actually gave her the
title and AOC had to invent this reason
to be disrespected the thing that's most
frustrating about the AOC comment isn't
even the you know constantly playing the
victim which AOC has to do the left
always has to do it's the just a
pridefulness of it do you remember there
was that guy lieutenant colonel vind
Minh he was is a liberal guy and he was
testifying and some some congressmen
referred to him as mr. Vinh Minh they
all refer to each other as mr. and mrs.
Wright and Binh Minh said excuse me ma
you wouldn't need to refer to me as
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh could give
me a break do take a freaking chill pill
I haven't tried yet
I promise you try just one little drop
of humility it will make your life
better if you live your life as someone
who's very prideful and you insist on
all the accolades and you insist on
getting every single thing you deserve
and constantly being being praised and
lauded you will not live a very happy
life if you're just thinking about every
slight that ever occurs to you or non
slight in the case of AOC imaginary
slight you won't be very happy but if
you try a little just a little touch of
humility you will feel much better that
you know the best professors I know
don't insist on being called doctor or
professor okay it's always the people
who are lower down the totem pole or
maybe their credentials are not as
impressive or maybe their work is not as
impressive
they're the ones who insist that call me
PhD call me M MD or something like that
it shows insecurity and it shows a real
narcissism but it drives people crazy
this is
drives people crazy there was a woman
that she went viral on the internet
because she was she received an email
for Trump supporters that said hey you
know if you donate now you'll get a free
hat that's what that's what the whole
email said donate now get a free hat
this woman has been worked up into such
an angry mad frenzy that she was
convinced this was evidence that Donald
Trump was Hitler and he was about to
launch another holocaust no I'm not
exactly the voice that people need to be
hearing right now um in fact I need more
confirmation that this is real I've
gotten some but I need more confirmation
that this is real Trump supporters got
an email that's of this email is paid
for patriots only you've been identified
as one of president Trump's fear systems
loyal defenders and according to your
donor file you'd make an excellent
addition to the Trump army it goes on to
tell them that they would get a
limited-edition camo keep America good
to let them know that you are the
president's first line of defense when
it comes to fighting off the liberal mob
I don't know if you know Hitler made
Jews wear yellow stars this feels like
the Berbers of that I don't know if you
know I don't know if you know but Hitler
had a hat he did I don't know if you
know this but he he drank water too and
Trump drinks water and it's basically
it's basically 1930s Germany except it's
not when I watch this I thought it was a
joke I thought it was satire I thought
this is funny this is cut this is the
most ridiculous exaggerated version of
what the Liberals do whenever Trump does
anything including give away a hat if
you donate some money through his
campaign no I was wrong I was wrong
because she clarified later and opposed
after this went viral that she was dead
serious
okay so for me at least this one friggin
blew up and you'll notice that I also
posted some other ones all concerning
the same thing but that's not how the
algorithm works so I have been told so
here's what basically went down me a
Jewish woman saw swastikas
all eyes matter lots of propaganda lots
of other World War two kind of Hitler II
stuff and so I also saw this email
saying that Trump supporters can donate
to get this hat to form an army a
clarifying thing that I found out from
people is that just because you are
registered Republican does not mean that
you've got this email but have you
donated to the Trump campaign then you
got the email Hitler did something very
very similar but sort of in the reverse
order by making Jewish people wear a
yellow star whereas now we are asking
Trump supporters to distinguish installs
with this special hat so yes this
freaked me out it should freak you out
too because he is identifying who to
protect rather than just labeling the
enemy so she's defending and she's
admitting she's like look I know this
went viral and everything but I know I'm
serious and here's here's why I reacted
the way I did I was totally right I
reacted the way I did because Hitler as
she did the same thing Trump did except
it was actually the opposite it was the
opposite but that's the fact that it was
the opposite is what's so similar about
it because you see like if she says
Hitler made Jews wear yellow stars which
is exactly like Trump giving out hats to
his supporters and you know you know the
craziest thing of all is if you work
yourself up into it this sort of
emotional frenzy that a left-wing
political leaders have whipped their
followers up into over the last few
years that actually makes sense it
actually I know it if you work yourself
up into that state that where you're
ready to go off on it on a hair-trigger
where you're so on edge which by the way
we have been in this country for at
least two months now at these lockdowns
with everything then any little even
remote resemblance to anything that you
know any basically any political action
Trump could take we'll send you off on
that hair-trigger believe it or not that
video was not the craziest thing to go
around the internet yesterday that that
particular award goes to the Minneapolis
City Council president
Lisa bender who was asked point-blank if
you abolish the police what happens if
crimes are being committed against you
who do you call and she said Oh what
nine eleven one nine eleven that's a
privilege we'll get to that one second
first though I've got to thank you I got
to thank you guys you we did it we ha we
did it we have passed drew Clavin on the
YouTube subscribers you know he he tried
to beat us he didn't even tell us that
he was doing this he got you but then we
pulled ahead we flew past with 50,000
subs thank you so much for doing that
really appreciate it that'll be fun to
brag about when I have a stogie with
rune x time i'm on the west coast head
on over that that YouTube channel you
know we try to we try to include some
extra content there I have an exclusive
interview with Timothy Gordon whose pal
of mine is a writer and a podcaster he
was fired for having the audacity to
criticize the radical leftist black
lives matter movement also look you know
you know how insane this whole year has
been and you know that the left-wing
media has only made it worse when you
can't get the real story you got to go
outside the narrative you got to go at
the facts that is why we want to offer
to you the readers pass now the readers
pass usually about 3 bucks a month ok
not not gonna break the bank and you get
exclusive insights and op-eds and
articles and things on the website but
for you for you amigo I am gonna offer
that for 99 cents for your first month
so head on over that's a two-thirds more
than a two-thirds discount you get
mobile and free access to the daily wire
news exclusive iPads and more on the
mobile app all for the low price of one
dollar for your first month
best of all your dollars are getting you
the news you need with that the left is
spin head on over to daily wire.com
slash subscribe join today we'll be back
with a lot more
so believe it or not the video of the
lady crying because President Trump's
campaign gave their donors free hats is
not the craziest thing going around the
internet
the craziest thing going around the
internet is this president of the
Minneapolis City Council Allison
cammarata on CNN asks her hey wait a
second if someone breaks into my house
to burgle me to rape me to harm me to
shoot me to who do I call if you've
abolished the police we have a state
action against our police department
which gives us legal mechanisms in the
very short term you know there is
lessons from all over the country all
over the world that we're looking to to
take immediate steps while we work
toward building the systems that we
would need to imagine that that future
do you understand that the word
dismantle or police free also makes some
people nervous
for instance what if in the middle of
the night my home is broken into who do
I call yes I mean I hear that loud and
clear from a lot of my neighbors and I
know and myself too and I know that that
comes from a place of privilege because
for those of us for whom the system is
working I think we need to step back and
imagine what it would feel like to
already live in that reality we're
calling the police may mean more harm as
done what where do we even begin on that
one it says hey what do I do if you
abolish the police and I need the police
to come there to stop the person trying
to kill me or anything and she says he's
right that's that's privileged you need
to understand that's a privilege and so
and imagine you know imagine the world
in which you know the police coming is
actually worse for you so first of all
that's not a world there's no world in
which people call the police and then
the police coming is worse for them then
the criminal just you know continuing to
attack them and take their stuff
shoot them whatever right that world
doesn't exist that's an imaginary world
but then the promise here is now
actually look it's it's privileged to be
able to call 911 to have the cops come
and stop the criminal you know imagine
imagine
world that would be otherwise than that
world you're living in now we don't have
to imagine it cuz you're abolishing the
police so that's about to become a
reality that reality is uniformly worse
for everybody and only in the insane
fantasy world of the left could that
possibly be an improvement now
some people are trying to spin this
because it's so radical it's so insane
this has been a demand of the black
lives matter movement to defund the
police to dismantle the police it is a
radical insane aim that Marxists have
been pushing for since the time of Karl
Marx but that no no serious person ever
really thought was going to be able to
be accomplished now it is going into
effect people are trying to spin it
they're saying no we're really just
talking about reform of the police no
we're really just talking about making
the police a little bit better
uh-uh that's not what we're talking
about they clarified this woman went
back on scene and they said are you
talking about reform she says no but to
be clear you're not talking about reform
the word dismantle is intentionally
different than reform this is more than
reform this is dismantling I mean
activists who support this are calling
this a police free future yeah if you
know a lot of us were asked if we could
imagine a future without police back in
2017 when we were running for office and
I answered yes to that question to me
that that future is a long way away and
it would take an enormous amount of
investment in things that we know work
to keep people safe I mean for a lot of
folks in our community stable housing is
a safety issue having access to
healthcare is a safety issue and so
having you know I think one thing folks
are asking is to stop investing so much
money in this militarized police force
and instead invest in the things that
our community really needs so you know I
know the statement was bold and I stand
by that bold statement but the work
ahead of us will be long it will include
every member of our community it has to
the statement was bold I stand by the
bold statement I'm not talking about
reform I'm talking about abolishing the
police now CNN like at least they've got
a few more brain cells to rub together
than the Mini
the City Council so they bring around
again they bring around again on Chris
Cuomo so he goes hey ah lady you're
making our jobs harder please like this
is a utopian thing police free it's not
gonna please just please say that you
that's not what you really mean
she triples down
when you say you see someday being
police free
that sounds aspirational in terms of a
utopian concept where nobody's
committing any crime because as long as
these communities are being preyed upon
both from within and without there's
gonna have to be good men and women
willing to step up to keep people safe I
think the idea of having a police free
future is very operational and I am
willing to stand with community members
who are asking us to think of that as
the goal because so many folks in our
community have seen us work on reform
okay okay so Cuomo strikes that
Cammarata strikes out Cuomo strikes that
this is crucial guys this is a crucial
moment because for a while it was only
the radical fringe lunatics who would
believe anything like this the kind of
going down to Marxist protests okay to
film to be part of it and I mean not to
participate in it but to antagonize them
and to you know cover what's going on
and that's the kind of stuff you would
hear with the radical Marxist protests
now it is leaking into the mainstream of
the Democratic Party in an election year
before a party convention they're trying
to move the presidential nominee so it
is crucial for them to get these elected
Democrats to stop talking about this
Cammarata strikes out Cuomo strikes out
Wolf Blitzer gives it one more try he
brings on a slightly more reasonable
Democrat as well no dice what happens if
there's a criminal out there with a gun
and start shooting people who's going to
respond if there's no police force look
it is our top priority to keep every
single member of our community safe and
if you look back at the last 150 years
of our Police Department it is becoming
increasingly clear that that model of
policing isn't working so we need to
invite in our whole community the nine
members of the City Council that came
from every corner of our city to stand
together to make this commitment we
don't have all the answers and what we
committed to was a community process to
help reimagine public safety so yes we
still have a police department in
Minneapolis today I hope it won't take
150 years to get to that looking forward
that next solution but we have a lot of
wisdom in
community we have invested in
community-based safety strategies we did
an analysis of all the reasons people
call 9-1-1 in our city to look at ways
we could have an appropriate response
yeah okay so the police thing isn't
working we're gonna get rid of it I just
make sure you take this point away the
left Democrats elected Democrats are
calling to defund to destroy to
dismantle the police it's not about
changing it it's not about reform that's
what they're gonna tell you even though
CNN struck out they're gonna keep
telling you that it's not what it's
about this woman could not have made
herself clearer obviously it's insane
the only problem with our police force
right now is they're not arresting
enough people we don't need to debunk
anything about about why it's wrong to
abolish the police we need to debunk a
different and more important line that's
one that's having a real consequences
around us the lie is this
we were told when we saw those videos of
insane snowflakes in college we were
told oh don't worry about them just wait
until they grow up and graduate and get
into the real world then they'll realize
how crazy they were I know that's not
what happened they graduated there in
the real world and now they're shaping
the real world and now the effect of
having this entire generation of coddled
uncultured uneducated people radicalized
left-wing people in the real world is is
to have the effect of changing the real
world to try to abolish the police to do
lots of other crazy things as well okay
we need to recognize the very pernicious
effects of that craziness in college
I've been talking about this for a long
time now how the educational system is
directly impacting our politics now we
finally get to see it hopefully not too
late you mean you saw this at the New
York Times New York Times a James
Bennett he was an op-ed editor at The
New York Times he had the audacity to
publish a column written by sitting
senator Tom cotton on the pressing issue
of the day how do we deal with the riots
there's a simple column Tom cotton said
yeah we should use the National Guard we
should use the troops to put down the
riots that the editor who accepted that
op e d just had to resign and the New
York Times issued a statement James
Bennet resigned on Sunday from his job
is the editorial page editor of the New
York Times the publisher AG Salt's
Berger says last week we saw a
significant breakdown in our editing
process not the first we've experienced
recent years both of us concluded that
James would not be able to lead the team
through the next leg of change that is
required now at the New York Times the
op-ed editor is not allowed to accept
op-eds
from people who are not radical leftists
huge change huge change you think of the
difference between Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and the modern slight of leftists is
noticeable consider this now the op-ed
page which the point of it is to publish
different people's opinions no longer
allowed to publish different people's
opinions speaking of different opinions
I do have to get to this real quick they
were this is just on coronavirus the
World Health Organization has a new
update on coronavirus you remember we
were told initially don't wear masks a
master bed then we were told you have to
wear masks masks are very important
first we were told the virus spreads
easily on surfaces then we were told the
virus doesn't spread easily on surfaces
then we were told you can't go out
because even if you don't have symptoms
the asymptomatic people are the ones
that are spreading the virus remember
that remember that it was totally wrong
World Health Organization now saying
that a symptomatic spread is very rare
coronavirus patients without symptoms
aren't driving the spread of the virus
we have a total breakdown here in the
credibility of our mainstream media of
our political leaders and of our public
health officials there is no reason to
believe anything that these people tell
you now I wish that we're not the case I
wish we could have some trust in our
institutions we simply can't they've
changed their tune every five minutes on
this whole thing before we go to another
campaign that's coming out of the left
right now talking about changing their
tune this one was my favorite
this is on a part of the BLM radical
left movement that we're seeing here
it's called the silence is consent
campaign major celebrities Sarah
Silverman uh sure cara de Lavigne yeah I
don't know who that is but she's
somebody with a blue checkmark or
something they're pushing this idea
silence is consent
did you catch what's wrong with that did
you catch the problem there silence is
most certainly not consent
Harvey Weinstein I think thinks that
silence is consent maybe Bill Cosby
thinks that silence is consent but the
say the very same left that has spent
now several years in the me2 movement
talking about how there's a rape culture
there's a widespread ramp
rape the campus at Harvard University is
more dangerous for women than Fallujah
because no one is getting consent and
even when women do give affirmative
consent sometimes that's not really
consent and we got to be SuperDuper
careful that same group of people is now
saying that silence is consent doesn't
make any sense
totally contradicts what they were
saying before it doesn't matter why
because anger is a very dangerous thing
because people when they get riled up
and crazed and hysterical in politics
they're much more easy to manipulate
especially by people who have long term
radical goals in mind
long term radical goals that they would
not otherwise be able to affect they can
do it when they with people into this
frenzy that you see all the way up to
the halls of Congress all the way down
to that crazy video of the lady talking
about head Trump giving away free hats
is basically a new Holocaust what do we
do about this I visited yesterday I'm in
Washington DC filming episodes of
verdict with senator Cruz I visited what
is now called black lives matter Plaza
it's the road right in front of the
White House that the mayor of DC renamed
and there were a lot of people out there
there's a lot of graffiti a lot of
damage because of all you know the
peaceful protesters and everything one
thing I noticed yesterday this black
lives matter movement which is I don't
know it because it's not about black
lives mattering I don't even want to
call it the black lives matter movement
I'll call it BLM the BLM movement is
incredibly well funded it's incredibly
well organized they've raised millions
millions of dollars in just the past few
days you can google it and they've got a
lot more money before that they've got
major donors too I know now that what
the left is saying is that it's a
conspiracy theory to point out that
George Soros the left-wing donor is
funding a lot of this but it's just
simply a fact you can look the founders
of the BLM movement all we're working
for organizations that were well funded
by the open society foundation which is
George Soros is organization it's not a
surprise Soros is the most prominent
influential left-wing funder in the
world so obviously a prominent left-wing
activist movement he's going to be
funding as well the BLM movement is just
so incredibly dishonest right but it's
effective and it's effective in part
because it's got this simple phrase
black lives matter a phrase that nobody
disagrees with right
so how do we counter that there are two
strategies one is you can support the
BLM organization even though it's
radically leftist this is like the Mitt
Romney approach right you say yeah no
I'm with you guys too I mean I don't
want to disband the cops and destroy the
nuclear family but no I'm with you guys
try to be kind of a squish and go along
and negotiate and come to a
reconciliation with them or we could
start a rival organization we could
learn a little bit from the left which
takes these innocuous phrases that
people agree with and use those phrases
to push down a radical agenda that whips
people up and and kind of allows them to
gives them something to hold on to I
think that's what the left that's what
the right rather has to do we need to
store a rival organization call it
support black lives call somebody
support black people I don't know
something like that an innocuous thing
we all agree with that allows us to
conserve some of our culture to push
worthy goals you know the BLM movement
is going going to destroy the country I
mean and by the way if BLM fizzles out
they'll they'll take another issue
they'll go on to gender issues or
they'll go on to environmental issues or
whatever but it's gonna be the same
radical left ISM behind it so what we
ought to do is start learning from those
tactics a little bit and give something
for people to hold on to as well call it
support black people so call it support
people of color or call it support women
call it support the environment whatever
but we've got a we've got to push in the
other direction because it's very clear
how fast this leftward lurch has been
accelerating they've been effective at
convincing people to go along with it if
we don't do something forget about
pointing out all the hypocrisy forget
about pointing out how wrong it is
forget about pointing out the dishonesty
if we don't actively do something to
oppose it they're gonna win they're
gonna gain more left-wing crown'd look
at how far they've come already all
right that's our show on Michael Knowles
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]